what else is new with you besides the
show or is that pretty all-consuming
it's very all-consuming I'm sort of
trying to keep
doing all my web stuff you know like
just like internet videos and you know
I'm posting less but it's it's always
like a it's like a debate it's like do
you dive fully into
the the bigger thing that you're doing
or do you want to also keep sort of your
other stuff that you've been doing going
and
yeah but but I'm doing both Megan came
out this this horror movie that he's in
yeah big hit huge hit yeah [__] were
like it's got like a 98 you [__] love
it it was great it was great you were
great then thank you so much yeah yeah
it's almost so is there gonna be another
one like are they yes Megan too yeah I
don't think I can say much but I'm
feeling happy
I'm a happy camper okay that's a no
um oh yeah there I am in the workshop I
have this I have this character I do
rich Southern ant which is like me in a
blonde wig I love that [__] character
thank you thank you but the in the movie
in this scene actually that's showing
here of like me in a workshop
I like throw a blonde wig on the table
as like a suggestion for Megan and so
people are constantly in my DMs being
like was that a reference to Rich
Southern ant I don't think it was but it
ends up it's like exactly her wigs
really maybe subliminally I was I was
referencing that I don't know but
they're also just different wigs around
and I just grabbed grabbed one you know
yeah see there it is I do like the new
one that you've been doing with the like
hot guy with the shitty voice oh yeah
wait have you have you used that filter
no it's so crazy wait it's the craziest
thing I'm not gonna say who and I'm I'm
sending love but somebody
I know somebody who uses this filter
uh I guess I can't yeah there it is
that's the filter and they post pictures
with this but they're doing it on ironic
no they like think they like think that
wait can we can you guys see this this
is Cody with the filter I look [__]
hot I know it's it makes I wish I
actually look like I know I know and
sometimes I'll post a video with this
filter on and people will like send me
heart eyes and I'm like do you think
this guy exists you're I don't you can't
tell me you think I look hot like this
that's not what I look like it's
actually really offensive I'm like okay
I guess go hook up with him or if if you
can find him it does kind of look real
I know I know I should get a bunch of
plastic surgery to look like that
honestly
it really is it makes a case for sort of
lowering the hairline expanding the chin
did you go oh yeah there's all this
stuff about Buckle fat removal
everybody's getting buccal fat removal
yeah beautiful isn't it I don't know no
I don't know I don't know Buckle no but
you know who definitely [__] got it
oh was uh uh from One Direction yes dude
what the [__] but sometimes I'm like
pull that picture up what's his name
again yeah Liam yeah Liam's sending love
I have something against Liam Payne
whatever wants to do you think Liam
Payne's gonna watch that he's watching
this right now and he's like I hope that
that one guy likes it so look at his
cheeks right like that is so what's
funny so obvious I really relate to his
desire to look this new way you know why
because I've always I've always had a
full face and so you see people with
these sallowed out faces but you're like
this is the dream but then yeah I'm
sorry but on the right it looks way way
worse no that's the lesson is like
basically don't get plastic surgery yeah
it'll look fake and bad like you never
want to look unnatural or fake because
that's the only thing you look like then
I know you know what the crazy thing
about really great plastic surgery is
though is you can't tell you wouldn't
know if you saw it yeah yeah so we don't
know it could be everywhere yeah it
could be on this show right no no I've
never had anything though
I keep telling my mom to get um BOTOX
for her migraines though you know they
can like put Botox in your neck and you
stop getting migraines oh really yeah
here's some here's some bug can we
figure out how to pronounce uh
[__] it really hits it's like get rid of
that it's like a little toes in here
suck that [__] out yeah I mean I guess I
once I went to a doctor this is a little
it's fine but one time I went to a
doctor and I was like I want to lose
weight and he was like you're already
underweight and I was like well I want
to lose weight anyway and he was like he
was like
he was like well I could do some lipo
sculpture around your face because I was
like I just want to look like skinnier
all around here and he was like offering
to do liposuction I was like I gotta get
out of here so that's kind of bugle fat
removal basically before it was a thing
I was asking for buccal fat removal yeah
and I'm glad it used to be called face
lipo back in the day yeah yeah it called
a lipo sculpt lipo sculpture and they
can take the the one I always think like
the one plastic surgery you can kind of
get away with is if you sort of if your
neck is getting really old and you kind
of yank that up I think you can get away
with that but it's good aging naturally
is great it is good I think sometimes
I'm like I would probably definitely get
a hair transplant you I mean if it ever
came into it if it ever came to it like
I see it's definitely starting to thin a
little bit no it's not you you you to me
are like a hair like you have the the
thickest strongest hair I've ever seen
thank you but I always notice it in
videos oh thank you I appreciate that
but I mean I like I see it's just from
wearing I think sometimes when I'm
training so much right I'm always
wearing a hat yeah yeah and then my
hormones are a little out of whack
sometimes I'm like [__] I can see it
start but I'm also like I'm almost you
know this year I'll be 33 so it's like
start this now is probably when it's
gonna start happening so if it did
happen I think I would consider getting
it yeah I agree they can really do that
now and apparently all the stars and
Holly all the male Stars they just all
happen yeah even if you're not losing
your hair that much you just kind of get
it filled in yeah yeah should we just
get our [__] like super low yeah Noel
and I have talked about that before
getting like a super low hair just bring
it down to the Brows yeah this is a
small little yeah
what do you mean what word what do you
mean no same same guy no work done do I
look different yeah
just because my hairline is at my
eyebrows you're saying I got something
done
and I think maybe I don't okay now I
probably wouldn't do this but I do like
the idea of having a beard and I can't
grow a beard so like the only way I
could grow a beard is to get beard
implants or something
like or just wear one of those like
things wait why are you laughing that's
real beard yeah you do the same thing
here that has never occurred to me yeah
I could use the same thing yeah because
I always see people with these Charming
five o'clock Shadows I don't grow hair
here I only grow go is that what you do
you only grow goatee I grow like here uh
but nothing here and here no I can do
that too but it's just it's not thick
yeah
yeah I know whenever I see people with
those with those nice with those nice
you know they grow it out for three days
and it's just creating some nice shading
there I'm like I just could never do
that I could grow a good mustache
but yeah would you you would but you
wouldn't really go get that done I think
that feels like
I don't know I don't know I don't think
I would maybe one day I don't know no I
don't think I would yeah plastic surgery
in general kind of scares me but yeah
it's such a slippery because like you
know they're like there's only so many
like looks you can do yeah as a guy yeah
right I did the long hair thing right
right now it's like what else is there I
know there's nothing really to keep like
I want to continue to sort of like try
and try different looks you know my dad
would like have a beard for a while and
then shave it off and it's like you're a
different dude for half the year yeah
yeah yeah yeah and you can go you have
eras exactly for me it's like this is my
one era now have you tried to be able to
grow a [__] beard and be a beard guy
for a while yeah and then you get into
beard oils and you get into I know a
nice Scotch drinking beard oils and
smoking beard oils
um what about uh a mustache if you try
growing a mustache yeah I did that
during covet and it did it work no I
mean just do we have pictures of Cody
with the most horrible
I had a mustache briefly once how does
it work for you it was really effective
and for what respect about what it was a
uh making me look like I had a mustache
um no it just I mean it was like a dense
it was like whoa what the fight wait is
this real no did you make who made that
wait that is impressive see I look
[__] hot as [__] wow not really but I
look like a rustic beer in case you were
wondering how Cody would have looked
with a beard
they like did this while we were
recording this yeah
um I look like the filter we don't have
mustache code oh there's mustache Cody
wait that's real right long hair
mustache that was uh click can we click
that I think I did have a mustache at
that point no no that's fake that's fake
too how is that fake
there there that one with Noel that's
what it actually looked like wait that's
awesome that looks like somebody
it looks it looks pretty horrible it
looks awesome it looks like Top Gun
maybe you could dye it dark the problem
with growing any facial hairs you have
to go through the period of time where
you just look like [__] for like two
weeks while it's growing out before it
really hits yeah yeah especially with a
mustache because then you have this just
like thin little like people are like
are you trying to grow a mustache yeah
you can use it as a bit right that's
true that's true
always good to have a little a little
bit yeah